next Thursday 7 out of 10 people in
England will go to the party you can
actually see the areas that are up for
election here on this map it's not
Scotland it's not Wales it won't be
Northern Ireland for a couple of weeks
at nor is it London these largely kind
of Metropolitan and Borough council's
230 of them over 8 000 seats are up for
Alexa but what's going to happen well
we've teamed up with yougov in order to
actually try and predict to project in
their language what's going to happen
they've actually identified 16 different
councils in that reflected a key
Battlegrounds in the forthcoming general
election so there's some in the red
walls um where labor have been under
pressure from the Tories some in the
blue wall where the conservative party
have been under pressure from the
liberal Democrats and then there are
just some of the key uh places that you
often hear about on Election night
because they represent big battles so
we've looked at all of them to to try
and come to the most comprehensive
picture possible let's start with what's
going on in the red wall now we've
picked up on a number of councils five
councils from Dudley in the West Midland
up to Darlington up in the teas Valley
and what the pattern here has been the
conservative party making advances in
the last few years in what traditionally
had been a labor Heartland so let's
watch what's going to happen you go
think next week and here it is you can
see actually labor making quite strong
advances where there are two arrows here
it means that they're going to be strong
gains for labor they predict now look at
Darlington currently the tourism have
been doing well and some no overall
control but that could fall into labor
hands that will be a good result for
labor it's not always quite hopeful that
some of the seats in the teas Valley
area might actually not fall to labor
because the influence of the teas Valley
bear Tori uh Ben Houchin but that might
not happen you could see one of the
conservative councils Northeast
Lincolnshire uh actually being lost it's
too close to call at the moment but that
suggests uh that actually it could fall
out of Tory hands look at this
Sunderland that might not look like it's
changing but what the significance of
Sunderland is that they had faced the
labor party in Sunderland quite a
challenge from the conservatives but
according to yougov not much to worry
about next week which I think is
interesting Kirsten will be pleased
about that then there's the blue wall
now this is traditional conservative
Heartland area look at the names here
wokingham that's of course uh working uh
John Webber's constituency Windsor uh uh
of course you have uh not only the queen
but Theresa Mays uh back yard this is
the kind of area where the conservatives
should feel pretty safe but after the
last few years British politics and
nobody can feel completely safe let's
look at what you go says will happen
there
and actually you can see it's pretty
Grim picture for the conservatives uh
they uh could lose Chichester they could
lose East Cambridge all the councils
around there have fallen away from
conservative control and ended up in
Liberal Democrat hand could that
actually go liberal Democrat this time
that you gov say too close to cool and
Theresa May's backyard uh Windsor that
is leading to no overall control you can
see the liberal Democrats doing really
quite well in places like Chichester uh
and uh Windsor so I think the liberal
Democrat story next week really shaping
up to be something uh quite interesting
but then there's one other type of seat
now these are the kind of seats all
around the country uh where really the
labor party and the conservative party
face it off and these are some of the
the key seats that control uh that could
swap sides until what's going on in the
councils are pretty important uh from
Swindon which I know that all the main
parties are looking at closely through
to Plymouth which the labor party think
are really important because of the
demographics there which represent the
wider country and here's what's
happening there now here what you can
see is in a lot of these there is some
sense of Labor Improvement in the uh in
the in the situation and you do have one
potentially standout result which would
be Swindon currently conservative
control actually leaning to go all the
way over to the labor party control that
means it doesn't end up uh in no overall
control it goes all the way strong
performance there elsewhere though
you're seeing just a single Arrow
suggesting that labor doing well but not
perhaps as well as they need to because
the enormous amount in uh to claim maybe
they get Plymouth as well maybe they can
take Worcester no sign of any
Improvement uh in South in the Southeast
Dartford in Kent doesn't look like
they're making any Headway there I think
you've got to think that these kinds of
councils um it's a perfectly respectable
performance from labor but given the
mountain they've got to climb perhaps
could be doing a little better from
these uh there's only six days to go
watch Sky News next Thursday night
Friday for the results we'll find out
whether these predictions turn out to be
true
very well Sam for now thank you